un jardin verdoyant une terrasse
bucolique la ville arabe les manoir
hôtel pittoresque de la fin du 19e
siècle est de nouveau au centre de
toutes les attentions
une bibliothèque gourmande sera
accessible pour la première fois au
public à partir du 9 juin
l'idée c'est de faire une sorte
d'université populaire en gros delà de
la cuisine de la gastronomie et que ce
lieu soit lieu de vie un lieu de passage
pour tous ceux qui s'intéressent à la à
la gastronomie qu'ils viennent s'y
donner rendez vous qu'ils y discute
qu'ils y est après l'échec associatif
sous l'ancienne municipalité
la nouvelle équipe tente donc de
relancer la tambouille gastronomique en
touraine jardin de la france se déployer
dans toute la ville c'est pas un lieu
au team a juste fait il tente en
plusieurs endroits plusieurs événements
plusieurs espaces pour que tout le monde
puisse s'y retrouver et sortir d'une
vision peut être parfois un peu élitiste
de la gastronomie la rend vraiment
accessible autres lieux et points forts
du développement de la cité de la
gastronomie version emmanuel denis
l'exploitation des étages supérieurs des
halles le ventre de la cité tourangelle
1900 mètres carrés à exploiter notre
ambition c'est de les utiliser pour que
les alv entre deux tours soit aussi un
lieu de dégustation un lieu où on
mettrait en avant les produits de nos
commerçants qui sont juste en dessous
pour nous c'est une vraie opportunité de
porter la transition alimentaire que
l'on souhaite porter et donc on souhaite
faire de ce lieu un vrai phare de la
gastronomie locale
reste la question financière si la
région s'est engagée à hauteur de 1,2
million d'euros
aucun budget global précis n'a été
présenté par la municipalité associée à
la métropole